Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Beim Mercedes-Benz Junior Cup, Deutschlands bekannteste U19-Turnier, spielen die Weltmeister von morgen, zumindest hofft man das. Wer genau ist das? Das wollen wir jetzt rausfinden in diesem Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Hallo und herzlich Willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Hier spricht ein etwas erkälteter Max Ackau Ostlich. Bitte die Stimmqualität zu entschuldigen. Und ein kleiner Disclaimer vorab. Ich bin beruflich bei Mercedes-Benz JuniorCup schon seit mehreren Jahren eingebunden. Das ist ein U19-Turnier in Sindelfingen, bei dem interessante Mannschaften antreten. Auch in diesem Jahr und in der Vergangenheit haben wir hier Spieler gesehen wie Joshua Kimmich, Sami Khedira, Manuel Neuer, Mesut Özil und so weiter und so fort. Das heißt, der Mercedes-Benz JuniorCup war häufiger schon ein guter Ort, um kommende Talente zu beobachten. Und das tun wir auch in diesem Jahr. Und erstmalig soll es dazu auch eine Rasenfunk geben. Es fließt dafür kein Geld, sollte es euch aber stören, dass ich das eigentlich hier beruflich gerade mache, dann macht das jetzt aus. Dann würdet ihr aber eine exquisite Runde an bekannten Persönlichkeiten der Fußballblase verpassen. Und zwar zu meiner Linken bei euch, Mono auf den Ohren, Arne Steinberg von sc.com. Servus Arne. Außerdem mit dabei Sebastian Rose vom Vertikalpass. Marc Schwitzki von HertheBase, die ja auch einen Podcast haben. Alex Feuerherr von Kolinas Abend.
Guten Morgen.
Und Martin Brinkmann von Mirsann Rot und der Mann, der mehr Spiele gesehen hat als Hermann Gerland. Hallo ihr alle zusammen. Schön, dass das hier klappt. Schauen wir mal, was das für eine Folge wird. Das ist ein Experiment. Es gibt einen Spiele, der bei diesem Turnier alle überragt. Wir müssen dazu sagen, wir haben einen von zwei Turniertagen gesehen. Und das ist Marc Arne Meyer. Woher kommt dieser Mann und warum ist er jetzt schon so gut?
Arne Meyer ist, glaube ich, seit er 15 oder 16 ist, ein ganz heißes Eisen in Berlin. Also es ist seitdem schon ein bekannter Name, bei dem alle sagen, also wenn es einer schafft, dann der. Interessant ist, dass Pardada ja bei Hertha als U15-Coach angefangen hat und da diesen berühmten, goldenen 99er-Jahrgang als Erstes betreut hat. Und jetzt kommen diese Talente in den Profibereich, auch mit seinem Sohn, auch mit Julius Kade, der auch einen Profivertrag hat, mit Dennis Smaas, der ja auch beim Turnier spielt und auch schon in der Europa League im Kader stand. Und Arne Maier ist ein interessanter Fall deswegen, weil er in seiner Jugendzeit oft verletzt war. Also er hatte ständig Leistenprobleme und ist deswegen ständig Wochen ausgefallen, konnte keine Saison durchspielen. Man hat sich gefragt, woran es liegt und tatsächlich lag das an der Fehlstellung seines Kiefers und er hat dann eine Zahnspange bekommen und seitdem nicht eine Beschwerde mehr gehabt. Also da war eine Zahnspange auf jeden Fall etwas sehr Erfolgsversprechendes für ihn. Und die trägt er bis heute und das tut ihm anscheinend gut, denn auch hier beim Turnier und auch in der Bundesliga und Europa League und Co. zeigt er ein beeindruckendes Niveau für einen 18-jährigen Jungen. Also in der Bundesliga konnte er sofort auf das Niveau adaptieren und hier beim Turnier schwebt er so ein bisschen über allen. Das merkt man schon, dass er da deutlich reifer und besser ist ein doofes Wort, glaube ich, aber reifer ist und gewisse Szenen einfach viel besser zu lösen weiß, als seine noch unerfahrenen Kollegen, die vielleicht auch noch keine Profiverfahrung haben.
Gibt es da von irgendjemanden hier Widerspruch in der Gruppe? Ich meine, wir hören natürlich auch denjenigen, dem Hertha BSC am Herzen liegt.
In der Tat wirkt Arne Meyer auf dem Feld dann schon so, als ob er mit jüngeren Jahrgang teilweise spielt, wenn man sieht, wie er dann vorne und hinten ist und durchgeht und er wirkt da einfach eine Stufe weiter schon als andere, stellen wir uns an.
Ich finde es auch interessant, dass er mehrere Positionen spielt. Manchmal baut er das Spiel von hinten heraus auf. Manchmal ist er der erste Spieler, der den gegnerischen Spielaufbau anläuft. Und egal, wo er spielt, hat er bisher gute Leistung gezeigt, würde ich sagen. Wahrscheinlich Spieler des Turniers. Gucken wir mal, wie es der zweite Gegner in der K.o.-Runde hat. Es hängt ehrlich gesagt immer viel darüber zusammen, ob man in das Finale kommt. Das kann ich schon verraten. Marc, wenn wir schon bei Hertha BSC sind, auf wen müssen wir denn noch in der Zukunft achten, der dir hier gut gefallen hat?
Deniz Marş habe ich ja schon angesprochen.
Der Torhüter.
Der Torhüter ist U-Nationalkeeper. So wie viele bei Hertha tatsächlich. Hertha hat in U19, U17 sehr viele deutsche U-Nationalkeeper. Nils Körber war ja auch in der U21 beispielsweise dabei. Marius Gersberg war da lange dabei. Und überzeugt hier als sehr sichere Nummer eins, hat fantastische Paraden teilweise gezeigt, also schon sehr viele Großchancen vereitelt. Sehr schnell unten, trotz, glaube ich, ziemlich enormer Körpergröße. Also scheint er schon ziemlich agil zu sein als Keeper. Auf so einem kleinen Feld kriegt man oft Schüsse aus kurzer Distanz drauf. Und dann so einen Reflex zu zeigen, ist schon besonders. Ansonsten haben wir hier zwei Spieler, die auch neben Arne Maier Profiverträge haben. Also Julius Kade beispielsweise, der hat jetzt um die 20 Bundesliga-Minuten gespielt und ein paar Europa League-Minuten. Das letzte Saison schon hoch gerutscht. Hat auch seinen Profiverträger unterschrieben. Ist ein offensiver Mittelfeldspieler, kann aber auch auf den Außen spielen zur Not. Agil, schnell, technisch, stark. Und in seinen zehn Minuten damals gegen Gladbach fand ich ihn auch schon sehr erfrischend. Wobei man sowas natürlich nicht überbewerten darf, da ist die Motivation dabei. Aber er ist zumindest aufgefallen. Und natürlich Pál, Pál Kodárdai. Der Sohn von unserem Trainer Pál Dádai, der auch schon Profiverfahrung gesammelt hat. Der gegen Östersund in der Europa League von Anfang an gespielt hat. Und da richtig gut gespielt hat, muss man dazu sagen. Also eine prägende Figur in dem Spiel. Ich finde sein Passspiel sehr stark. Seine Pässe kommen meistens gestochen scharf. Und dennoch gut auf den Mann. Er ist manchmal noch zu eindimensional in seinem Spiel, weil er auf dem rechten Flügel spielt und eigentlich immer nach innen ziehen will. Aber wenn er das noch ein bisschen variantenreicher gestalten kann, glaube ich, dass er einer für die Zukunft sein kann, weil er technisch auf einem sehr guten Niveau ist. Klar, Kade und Dardai wiegen beide zusammen so viel wie Jérôme Boateng, würde ich sagen. Aber daran lässt sich ja noch arbeiten. Und dementsprechend hat man da drei bis vier Talente, die schon den Sprung schaffen können oder sogar schon geschafft haben.
Die Massephase, die kommt noch.
Was mich beeindruckt hat – ich bin da jetzt nicht für die Spieler da, sondern eigentlich für die Schiedsrichter – was mich beeindruckt hat, und wir hatten gestern schon kurz darüber gesprochen, ist, dass es offensichtlich bei Hertha BSC so eine Art Patensystem gibt. Also wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, hat jeder Profi einen Jugendspieler, den er sozusagen so zu betreuen hat, zu coachen hat, zu mentoren hat, wie auch immer man das nennen will. Sowas kenne ich aus der Schiedsrichterei. Das ist eine ganz interessante Querverbindung.
Sowas kenne ich aus dem Kindergarten.
Jetzt musst du mal überlegen, was in diese drei Personengruppen verbindet. Das wird wahrscheinlich so schwierig sein. Bei den Schiedsrichtern ist das zumindest bei uns im Mittelrhein, im Kreis Köln dann auch so, dass wenn neue Schiedsrichter ausgebildet werden, gerade wenn sie minderjährig sind, eigentlich nur dann, dann bekommen sie einen erfahrenen Coach zur Seite gestellt. Erfahrene Schiedsrichter zur Seite gestellt. Er ist ein bisschen coacht, ein bisschen durch die ersten Spiele führt. Das System geht dann weiter. Ich habe ja selber zwei sogenannte Mentees, also denen ich quasi als Coach, als Mentor diene, die ich so ein bisschen durch die Saison bringe. Und offensichtlich gibt es das aber auf der Basis auch. Das fand ich sehr spannend. Du sagtest auch gestern, dass es eigentlich kein Training gibt, in dem nicht wohl auch mehrere Spieler aus der Jugend teilnehmen. Und das ist ja schon noch ein besonderes Fördersystem ganz offensichtlich.
Ja, absolut. Also Dadej kommt wie gesagt aus der Jugend als Trainer. Er hat bei der U15 angefangen bei Hertha. Ist ja dann sofort Pro-Uffi-Trainer geworden. Also die nächsten Schritte im Jugendbereich hat er dann nicht mehr mitgemacht. Aber seit ihm ist bei Hertha ein sehr einheitliches Fördersystem für Talente entwickelt worden. Also Pall Dadej hat mit Ante Czović einen ganz wichtigen Ansprechpartner. Der ist U23-Coach und nennt sich auch irgendwie Karrierecoach oder ähnliches, weil er die besondere Aufgabe hat, Talente von der U19 bis in den Profibereich zu führen. Also er entscheidet zusammen mit Trainer Michael Hartmann, der U19-Trainer ist, und Pall Dadej zusammen, setzen sie sich jede Woche zusammen und entscheiden, wer jetzt in welcher Mannschaft eingesetzt wird. Ob U19, U23, ob er in den Profi-Kader rutschen könnte. Und was Trainingslager und normale Trainingseinheiten angehen, das ist richtig, dass es keine Trainingsseinheit ohne irgendwelche Talente gibt, die einfach mal schnuppern dürfen. Michael Preet sagt immer wieder den Satz, die Tür ist offen für jeden. Und wer sich dann in der U23 oder U19 empfiehlt, darf bei den Profis mittrainieren. Einige machen das aber auch schon sehr regelmäßig. Also Julius Kade beispielsweise, der trainiert ja auch schon durchgehend mit den Profis. Aber so empfehlen sie sich halt. Und diese Durchlässigkeit ist bei Hertha, glaube ich, gerade ein Riesenthema. Und das sieht man ja auch, dass unter Daday in Mittelstedt entdeckt wurde, in den Turunariga und jetzt seit der 99er Jahrgang. Das sind, glaube ich, schon Erfolge für jemanden, der jetzt erst zwei, zweieinhalb Jahre Trainer bei Hertha ist. Und dementsprechend ist er schon sehr erfolgreich bis jetzt.
Also ich habe bisher gelernt, es gibt Mänties, und das sind nicht Männer-T-Shirts. Das bist du abgesprochen. Und bei Hertha spricht man über den Jahrgang 99 wie über einen guten Wein. Und die Durchlässigkeit ist da. Jetzt hat gerade der FC Bayern Martin viel Geld in die Hand genommen und ist auch ganz, ganz stolz auf sein neues Nachwuchsleistungszentrum. Wie sieht es denn mit der Durchlässigkeit bei den Bayern aus? Und ist dir in dem aktuellen U19-Team jemand aufgefallen?
Die Durchlässigkeit wird sich natürlich im Zweifel in der Zukunft zeigen. Der FC Bayern hat andere Herausforderungen, andere Möglichkeiten als Hertha. Es wird natürlich auch eine große Frage, welcher Profitrainer im Sommer, oder im Sommer 2019, da war noch immer die Nachfrage, wie von Jupp Heynckes antritt.
Da hätten wir einen eigenen Kurzpass zu machen können. Wir haben ja einfach mitgeschnitten, was wir gesprochen haben gestern. Das wäre auch eine schöne Sendung geworden.
Ja, es ist natürlich schwierig bei der Kaderbreite der Profis. Wichtig war jetzt erstmal, was sie auch in den letzten Jahren gemacht haben, die allgemeine Qualität, die bei uns nachkommt, wieder zu erhöhen. Das ist jetzt offensichtlich der Fall. Das haben wir auch in den Ergebnissen gesehen letztes Jahr mit der Vierzermaiserschaft der A-Jugend und der Meisterschaft der B-Jugend. Wer es dann am Ende schafft, ist natürlich immer so ein bisschen der Zufall. Das liegt auch an der Position, wo vielleicht gerade eine Vakanz bei den Profis ist. Links verteidige Position ist da immer so eine schöne Sache. Und beim Lassemai, der bei den Profis jetzt auch in Doha dabei ist gerade, gestern sein Einsturzlied gesungen hat mit Sandro Wagner zusammen. Da fehlt ja einer der heißen Kandidaten und der Oliver Tister-Meier, der ist mit der Junioren-Anschaffung im Trainingslager, der ist auch nicht dabei. Das sind natürlich schon die beiden heißen Eisen und Feuer, die jetzt da heute fehlen. Berlin hat einem Arne Meier genau das Gegenteil gemacht, nämlich die heißen Eisen mitführen.
Finde ich auch sehr interessant.
Obwohl er für die Profis die Vorbereitung auch in der heißen Phase ist. Das finde ich schon interessant. Aber ich hätte jetzt gesagt, dass Arne Meier auch schon aktuell, vor allem körperlich deutlich über den beiden Bayern-Spielern anzudrücken ist. Arne Meier passt halt zwischen seinen technischen und Spielintelligenz-Fähigkeiten und wie er körperlich weit ist. Das ist schon eine gute Mischung. Ich kenne schon sehr viele Nachwuchsspieler in dem Alter. Und ich sehe auch viele. Aber Arne Meier, würde ich jetzt sagen, ist in der Saison in dem Alter das Beste, was ich gesehen habe.
Das freut mich.
Das freut mich, dass es ihr sehr gut tut. Wie viel wir hier über HrTWC reden. Lass uns doch mal ein paar Namen rauspicken. Wer optisch aufhört beim FC Bayern in der U19 ist Manu Windsheimer, weil er eine Liederrolle annimmt, die aber auch beinhalten, viel zu reklamieren, aggressiv in Zweikämpfe zu gehen und manchmal auch den Schuss zu viel zu nehmen. Das ist jetzt meine Einschätzung. Wen gibt es denn daneben noch, wo man sagen kann, vielleicht schaffen diejenigen es ja auch nicht beim FC Bayern, aber man kann ja dann auch zu Hoffenheim und Hertha und an eine tolle Karriere starten und wieder zurückkommen und die Rücknummer 2 kriegen, das geht ja auch.
Ja, es gibt da schon ein paar Junior Natar-Spieler, jetzt auch der Alex Nitzel, dem ist jetzt keiner aufgefallen.
Auch Kapitän?
Auch Kapitän.
Warum ist dir keinem aufgefallen?
Es ist ja auch vielleicht nicht der halbe Fußball, den wir hätten auf kleinerem Feld, der Fußball, der jedem Spieler entgegenkommt. Der Alex Nitzel ist eigentlich Innenverteidiger, kann das natürlich in einer Halle mit dem Stellungspiel nicht supprilieren, wie jetzt im freien Feld.
Auch mit seiner Kopfballstärke, die ist da weniger gefragt.
Ich glaube, wir haben das sogar am Kopfballtor gesehen gestern.
Ja, Hoffenheim gegen Athen hat einen Kopfballtor gemacht, aber das war eine Phase des Spiels, da ging alles, da hätte auch ich getroffen. 7-1, das ging es glaube ich aus.
7-2. Ich finde den Südkoreaner von Bayern durchaus auffällig. Wie heißt er?
Ich sehe ihn das erste Mal dieses Jahr, weil der Wechsel ist im Sommer bekanntgegeben worden. Aber er hatte erst am 20. September Geburtstag gehabt. Bayern durfte nach den FIFA-Regularien den erst jetzt zum ersten Jahr erholen. Das ist quasi ein erster Auftritt in Deutschland. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen schwer einschätzen. Keiner von uns weiß, wie die Liga in Südkorea, die U19-Liga, da ist. Vorurteilsmäßig würde ich jetzt sagen, die Koreaner sind halt alles so Chris-Spall, würde man auf Bayerisch sagen. Also, technisch fein und körperlich vielleicht ist nicht ganz auf europäischem Niveau. Das wird natürlich spannend, wie er jetzt mit der europäischen Spielweise, die halt deutlich körpergewirkt wird. Und da vermute ich jetzt mal, wie er damit zurechtkommt. Ist das eine Premiere bei den Bayern? Oder dass die jungen, ausländischen Spieler in die eigene Jugend holen? Oder passiert das häufiger? Es passiert selten. So, Südkoreaner. Ich glaube, Asiaten haben wir noch gar nicht gehabt. Wir haben mal einen aus Peru gehabt mit 13. Das ging von dem seinen Berater aus. Der ist auch irgendwie nach einem halben Jahr unglücklich, sehr unglücklich wieder zurückgegangen nach Peru. Sonst konzentrieren sie sich jetzt schon eher auf das europäische Ausland, wo es ja auch mit den Regularien einfacher ist.
Hatten sie nicht irgendeinen Schweden oder Skandinavier jetzt in die Jugend geholt?
Ja, sie haben nur Thomas Ischewood vor zwei Jahren mal geholt. Den Rian Johansson, der klingt schwedisch, ist aber eigentlich Luxemburger. Der kann auch für Schweden spielen. Das ist so ein Babelschatzbürger. Alex Timm is hier anders, der spielt aber in Norwegen, in Schweden. In Schweden spielt er noch bis zu 2019. Den haben sie schon ein paar Jahre im Voraus gesichert. Aber er spielt immer in der ersten Liga. Vielleicht auch körperlich viel besser zur Entwicklung als in Deutschland zu spielen.
Schauen wir mal, welchen Bein, welchen Sandro Wagner wir vielleicht übersehen haben. Generell finde ich es schwierig, die Stürmer bei Hallenfußball nicht überzubewerten. Es ist schon auffällig, dass meistens diejenigen, die uns aufgefallen sind gestern, auch diejenigen sind, die in Dribblings gehen, die gute Pässe spielen oder Abschlüsse haben. Das hat natürlich auch der Hallenfußball an sich, dass es schwieriger ist, Defensivleistungen einzuordnen. Da war Kimmich vor zwei Jahren noch eine Ausnahme. Da hat man auch schon deutlich gesehen, das war ähnlich wie Anne Meyer, der war schon sehr dominant auf dem Platz. Aber das ist so der Beiers, den man im Hallenfußball hat. Was macht denn der 1. FC Köln, Arne? Bist du zufrieden?
Bisher haben sie sich insgesamt ganz gut verkauft, nachdem sie einigermaßen schwierig mit zwei Niederlagen gestartet sind. Aber durch die beiden Siege hat man sich für den 2. Turniertag in relativ gute Positionen bekommen. Man kann theoretisch sogar noch das Halbfinale erreichen. Welche Bedeutung das jetzt hat, ins Halbfinale zu kommen, möchte ich jetzt auch nicht überbewerten, denn in der Jugendausbildung geht es ja auch nicht immer nur um die Erfolge. Ich glaube, da war es dann in der jüngeren Vergangenheit zumindest so, dass aus der Jugend des 1. FC Köln relativ viele Spieler im Seniorenbereich schon Verantwortung übernehmen mussten. Aus verschiedenen Gründen – Verletzungen, Krankheiten, Profikader. Und das hat, wenn wir schon über Durchlässigkeit sprechen, dann relativ gut funktioniert. Die haben sich schnell akklimatisieren können. Und da würde ich gerne noch ergänzen, dass dieses System mit Jugendspielern aus den verschiedenen Stufen, die dann teilweise im Profi-Training dabei sind, jetzt nichts ist, was Hertha PSC exklusiv hat. Es ist tatsächlich etwas, was es überall gibt und dann natürlich in unterschiedlichen Ausprägungen. Aber ich glaube, der 1. FC Köln ist da auf einem guten Weg. Natürlich, wenn man sich jetzt die U19 anschaut, diesen Jahrgang muss man auch sagen, dass aktuell noch nicht feststeht, wer der neue Trainer wird. Das ist dann natürlich auch nochmal so ein Punkt, was die Sache für die Spieler ein bisschen schwieriger macht. Aber trotzdem finde ich, es ist eine gute Möglichkeit, sich zu präsentieren bei so einem Hallenturnier, weil man da sieht – und da würde ich auch ein bisschen widersprechen wollen – wer in seiner Ausbildung schon relativ komplett ist. Weil das ja auch ein Ziel ist, das von vielen Vereinen angestrebt wird. Und das sieht man eben beim Hallenfußball tendenziell eher, weil da die Rate an Aktionen, defensiv und offensiv, relativ groß ist. Und man daher sehen kann, wer auch schnell mal umdenken kann. Und ich glaube, da ist es wichtig, dass sich junge Spieler unter diesem Zuschauerzuspruch, den es gibt, präsentieren können. Und natürlich auch Fernsehen, was ja auch nicht selbstverständlich ist für Junior- und Bundesligaspieler.
Das ist ja der Grund, warum das Teilnehmerfeld auch sehr prominent besetzt ist. Und zwar in jedem Jahr. Also jetzt haben wir ja hier mit Köln, Stuttgart, Hertha, Bayern, Panathinaikos, Krasova Zürich und Wikengur Reykjavik. Ich hoffe, jetzt habe ich gerade keinen vergessen. Ja, TTSG aus Hoffenheim natürlich noch. Also das Teilnehmerfeld hier ist sehr präsent. Und ich habe mit Norbert Elgert gesprochen von Schalke 04, die auch hier Stammgast waren in den letzten Jahren. Der hat gesagt, wenn ich die Chance habe, dass meine Spieler mal vor, ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht, wie viele in den Klasspalast Sindelfingen passen, ich würde sagen 2000 Leute. 5000, 5000, 5000. Ja, guck mal an, der Max hat einfach ein Händchen für Menschen.
Er stapelt halt tief.
Wenn ich die Chance habe, denen die Erfahrung zu geben, dass die zwei Tage mal vor so einer Masse an Leuten spielen, vor allem jetzt am Finaltag, wo es dann auch ein bisschen aufgeheizter wird, dann muss man das eigentlich wahrnehmen als Trainer. Und dann sieht man auch, wie Spieler mit dem Druck umgehen. Ich finde, das hat man auch in der Auseinandersetzung mit den Schiedsrichtern, über die wir gleich noch sprechen wollen, auch gesehen, wie unterschiedlich da der Frust abgebaut wird bei den Spielern. Also das stimmt schon. Und generell sieht man, wie sich der Jugendfußball weiterentwickelt hat. Also Tobias Escher, der auch hier vor Ort ist, mit dem habe ich gestern darüber gesprochen, der ist jetzt auch schon zum vierten Mal hier, so wie ich auch. Und man sieht deutlich mehr Dribblings zum Beispiel als noch im letzten Jahr. Im letzten Jahr haben wir noch kritisiert, dass die kaum in Zweikämpfe gegangen sind. Es gab ganz, ganz viele Passstaffetten, die aber sehr unfruchtbar waren. Dieses Jahr hat man wieder so 2-3 Spieler, die auch ins 1 gegen 1 gehen. Weiß nicht, ob man da ein Trendfest machen will, aber ist auf jeden Fall interessant. So wichtig an dieser Folge ist ja, dass wir möglichst viele Namen droppen, damit ich, wenn der, ja derjenige, nicht diejenige, derjenige, dann Weltmeister wird, dass ich dann nur diesen einen Schnipsel rausnehmen kann und sagen kann, im Rasenfunk wusstet ihr es schon immer. Deswegen, Anne, musst du jetzt noch ein paar Namen sagen.
Ich wollte den ganzen Kader jetzt vorlesen, tatsächlich nicht, aber ich tue mir das auch schwer, jetzt jedem einen rauszunehmen, denn man hat natürlich dann den Reflex, sich die Spieler auszusuchen, die für spektakuläre Aktionen stehen, die viele Tore schießen. Und da gab es ja beim FC Köln jetzt beispielsweise gestern dieses Fallrückzieher-Tor, da will ich jetzt auch gar nicht mehr darauf eingehen, aber bei mir ist es so, dass mir von seiner Art her Fußball zu spielen, wenn Rüdmüller sehr gut gefällt, ist auch als Kapitän unterwegs, weil man bei ihm eben schon merkt, dass er sich auch um seine Mitspieler kümmert und weniger um sich selbst. Er versucht zu pushen, er versucht seine Mitspieler zu stellen und da sieht man dann schon auch, und das ist auch bei Arne Maier der Fall, wie weit ein Spieler ist, wenn er eben schon sich dann um die Belange der Mannschaft kümmern kann nebenbei. Und da ist er mir positiv aufgefallen. Dass er ein gesundes Maß an Aggressivität und Ehrgeiz mitbringt, ist sicherlich auch nicht schädlich. Und die Spiele, die ich von dem jetzigen Jahrgang auch in der A-Junior-Bundesliga gesehen habe, die haben mich da auch jetzt so ein bisschen darin bestätigt, dass er auf einem guten Weg ist, auf jeden Fall, was das angeht.
Dann war Holtmann auch nie so schlecht, fand ich. Nicht nur, weil er ein recht spektakuläres Tor erzielt hat. Ausgerechnet gegen den FC Bayern. Solche Geschichten schreibt ausschließlich der Fußball. Den fand ich noch ganz gut. Womit wir beim VfB Stuttgart gekommen sind, über den wollte ich jetzt natürlich als nächstes sprechen. Meine Güte, so eine Erkältung macht sie doch ein bisschen bemerkbar. Der VfB Sebastian, komischerweise immer mit dabei bei diesem Turnier hier in Sindelfingen. Man weiß nicht so genau, warum. Zum 28. Mal findet der Metsis Benz JuniorCup statt. Ich glaube, zum 27. Mal ist der VfB dabei. Und wir zwei haben jetzt ja auch schon ein paar Turniere hier gesehen. Und der VfB hat immer so eine Sonderrolle, weil viele Fans in der Halle für den VfB sind vor allem am Finaltag. Ist damals noch ein bisschen enttäuschend. Aber auch, weil der VfB ja eine gute Jugendarbeit hat. Und das hat man hier immer wieder auch am JuniorCup gesehen. Deswegen gewinnt der VfB auch recht häufig dieses Turnier. Wer ist dir denn in diesem Jahr aufgefallen?
Ich bin erstmal ein bisschen neidisch, wenn ich eure Spielerbogen von euren Clubs gesehen habe, wo hinter den Namen ganz oft irgendwie stand DFB-Auswahl. Das gibt es beim VfB aktuell nicht. Und die Durchlässigkeit, die wir jetzt schon öfter angesprochen haben, die ist beim VfB meiner Meinung nach gerade relativ gering. Weil wir hatten in der vergangenen Saison, in der Hinrunde, gab es, glaube ich, einen U23-Spieler, der für ein VfB ein paar Minuten im DFB-Pokal gespielt hat. Das war Pascal Breier, der ist jetzt zur Rostock gewechselt. Und der Nicolas Sessa ist häufiger im K, da schafft es aber irgendwie nie ins Spiel. Und die große Diskussion in Stuttgart ist ja gerade, ob die U23 abgeschafft wird. Und ich glaube, wir haben hier in Sindelfingen vor zwei Jahren BKH angesehen. Und das war der letzte, wo man den angesehen hat, der kann das wirklich packen. Und der es dann auch geschafft hat, jetzt halt in die Ligamannschaft, in die erste Mannschaft. Jetzt gestern fand ich, war es eine gute Mannschaftsleistung. Jetzt, wenn man einen rausnehmen will, wäre es natürlich der Torwart, der Jerome Weisheit, weil er das erste Tor des Turniers für den VfB erzielt hat, was ja dann auch etwas ganz Besonderes ist.
Aber er war schon sehr platziert, oder?
Er hat auch so überhaupt nicht darauf reagiert. Na gut, da die Hörerinnen und Hörer das wahrscheinlich nicht mitbekommen haben, wollen wir uns da nicht in Details verstricken.
Genau, und wer jetzt noch auffällig war auf jeden Fall, ich weiß jetzt nur nicht, ob er einfach nur auffällig war oder ob er auch gut auffällig war, also er ist nicht negativ aufgefallen, der Benjamin Hacic, der von Bayern letztes Jahr kam, der ist sehr präsent auf dem Platz mit dem nächsten Weltmeister, wird es für ihn aber schwierig, denke ich, weil er aus Bosnien her zur Gowina kommt. Also das halte ich für fraglich, ob er da Weltmeister wird oder wie gut er auch sein mag. Das sind so die zwei, die mir ein bisschen aufgefallen sind. Und natürlich dann der Erik Hottmann durch seinen Wahnsinns-Tor gegen die Bayern halt. Nach dem 17. Spieltag in der Bundesliga war das so ein kleines bisschen Genugtuung.
Ja, aber das war ja schon interessant zu sehen. Die Bayern waren nicht Reykjavik, nicht Banatinaikos, sondern die Bayern waren das Team, wo man am meisten physischen Verfall gesehen hat, im Verlauf dieses ersten Turniertags. Wahnsinnig krass abgebaut, nach hinten raus. Das ist jetzt aber nichts, was man schon beobachten konnte in der Junioren-Bundesliga.
Ja, allgemein gefällt mir die Entwicklung von der A-Jugend nicht so gut. Der Trainer oder auch die Öffentlichkeit hat es am Ende ein bisschen darauf geschoben, dass natürlich die jungen Spieler mit der Belastung – wir haben ja auch Youth League gespielt unter der Woche sechsmal – und zwei Spieler waren auch bei der Weltmeisterschaft in Indien im Oktober, über vier Wochen, da haben sie ein bisschen auf diese Belastung geschoben. Das war mir aber zu billig. Ich denke, dass wir keine gute Entwicklung in Sachen Taktik machen, dass die Spieler eigentlich schlechter werden. Wir haben gegen Abstiegskandidaten wie Wien-Wiesbaden oder Karlsruhe nicht gewonnen, doch gegen Wien-Wiesbaden haben wir sogar gewonnen. Da war ich recht glücklich vor kurzem Schluss. Das gefällt mir eigentlich nicht. Das hat man gestern im Turnier auch gesehen. Wir lieben es vom ersten Spiel, wo wir gegen Hoffenheim recht gut gestartet sind. Vier zu drei hat man eigentlich gedacht, der FC Bayern schlägt den Titelverteidiger so spektakulär. Der Titel kann ja nicht nur in den FC Bayern gehen. Dann war es zweites Spiel gegen Köln schon bescheiden, würde ich sagen.
Das war, fand ich, ein emotionaler Höhepunkt dieses Turnier-Tags, weil man gesehen hat, was es für die Banatinaikos-Spieler bedeutet hat, gegen den FC Bayern zu gewinnen. Vorher haben sie noch zwei zu sieben gegen Hoffenheim verloren. Und körpersprachlich war da wenig Gegenwehr zu erkennen. Das hat sie ein bisschen genervt, aber war denen auch egal. Aber gegen Bayern sind sie mit so einem Feuer in das Spiel gegangen. Das fand ich richtig cool zu sehen. Und das macht es auch so spannend, dass man diese ausländischen Exoten mit dabei hat, immer wieder hier beim Turnier. Da war ja auch schon Manchester United mit dabei. Oder letztes Jahr die U19 Südkoreas. Da war das Ganze ähnlich. Und jetzt haben wir noch die Isländer, die aber immer noch, wenn ich jetzt nicht in meinem vernebelten Hirn irgendwas rumschweiße, noch auf ihren ersten Sieg warten. Da werden wir heute hart für Jubel müssen, finde ich. Ich werde meine Stimme verlieren, wenn dann für Island. Aber das fand ich schon interessant zu sehen. Und Tobiasz hat dann die interessante Frage gestellt, warum spielen denn eigentlich die Bundesligisten nicht, auch ähnlich gegen die Bayern? Also Panathinaikos war die Mannschaft, die am eindeutigsten dieses Spiel unbedingt gewinnen wollte, während alle anderen so, ja, naja, wir gucken jetzt halt mal. Und dann wird es halt ein 1-1, ein 1-2, vielleicht ein 2-1. Fand ich einen interessanten Punkt.
Ja, weil Panathinaikos hat ja jetzt schon auch diese recht klassische Taktik angewandt, sich halt in Sicherheit 3 zu stellen. Ich glaube, die haben nun eine 3-2-Taktik gespielt. Aber halt dann das Glück gehabt, dass sie recht früh, glaube ich, das Tor gemacht haben, was ihnen entgegengekommen ist. Und Bayern hat halt wenig Ideen im Spielaufbau, viele Fehler von den Innenverteidigern, sage ich jetzt mal in Anführungsstrichen, weil das ist nicht alles unbedingt Innenverteidiger, die da in der freiheitlichen Innenverteidigung spielen. Dann verlierst du halt so ein Spiel schnell. Und dann ziehst du aus der zweiten Reihe ab und hast gute Schüsse. Das Problem ist ja auch, dass wenn sie schießen, dann schießen sie immer alle drei Meter zu hoch. Das ist, glaube ich, allgemein ein Problem beim Turnieren, dass keiner versteht, dass man flach schießen muss in der Halle. Weil die Tore sind auch nicht so hoch und du musst eigentlich unten links oder unten rechts immer treffen. Weil die Tore da den weitesten Weg haben, mit ihrer Hand hinzukommen. Und wenn du da halt keine Ideen hast und keine guten Abschlüsse hast, dann verlierst du so ein Spiel. Und natürlich ärgert mich, weil Pajtaiakos halt recht – ich sag mal – einen anfänglichen Blick gegen uns gewonnen hat mit der Taktik. Aber halt mit viel Einsatz. Und dann läuft es halt so, wenn du es nicht selber den Kampf annimmst.
Ja, gerade in der Halle geht das ja sehr schnell. Also ich glaube, da muss man jetzt irgendwie der Mannschaft auch keinen großen Vorwurf machen. Da kann sich das Blatt so schnell drehen. Durch ein, zwei Aktionen und dann verbleibt nicht viel Zeit. Und wenn der Gegner sich einigermaßen gut positioniert, dann verliert man eben so ein Spiel.
Das finde ich übrigens interessant, weil jetzt loben wir alle Hertha. Aber Hertha hätte fast gegen VfB verloren. Da stand noch eine Minute Verschluss. 4 zu 3 für VfB und dann stand es 4 zu 5 für Hertha. Ja, oder andersrum. Es stand 3 zu 3 für VfB, eine Minute Verschluss. Und dann hat Hertha 4 zu 3 gewonnen. Könnte jetzt auch ganz schön anders sein, die Ausgangssituation. Die hätte vielleicht das Spiel verloren hätte. Also es war so ein Moment, wo halt so eine kleine Aktion entscheidet.
Stimmt, aber trotzdem sehe ich die Hertha noch am konstantesten bisher, was die bisherigen Leistungen angeht.
Vor allem, die haben auch so eine abgeklärtheit. Also in der Halle geht es auch viel um Emotionen, finde ich. Oder man bekommt die Emotionen näher mit, was auch so… Also in der letzten Spielminute wirft nochmal DJ Ralf oder DJ Alex was. DJ Alex wirft dann nochmal irgendeine… eine bekannte Pop-Nummer, die man mit einem ordentlichen 120er-Beat unterlegt hat, nochmal an. Das ist, glaube ich, auch gerade für die Schiedsrichter doch gar nicht so gut, Alex, oder? Also man hat ja schon gesehen, und das wird man heute im Finale noch deutlich erkennen, da kochen die Emotionen manchmal ganz schön hoch.
Das ist so wie in der regulären Spielzeit, nein, in regulären Spielen, halt in der Nachspielzeit, ne? Deswegen ist das bei den Schiedsrichtern ja auch so gefürchtet. Also man muss dazu sagen, die muss man natürlich trotzdem geben, aber da kulminiert das natürlich und wenn die Musik da losgeht, dann steigt bei den Schiedsrichtern auch der Puls, klar. Insbesondere dann natürlich, wenn so ein Spiel noch, wenn es knapp zugeht. Wie wir das jetzt im ersten Turnier da ein paar Mal gesehen haben, sogar noch mal mit gedrehten Spielen, das ist dann auch für die Schiedsrichter eine Herausforderung, klar.
Jetzt dreht man im JuniorCup immer wieder Profi-Schiedsrichter an, Schiedsrichter, die man kennt, Knut Kirchhaar hat hier gepfiffen, Bibiana Steinhaus war hier, hier hat die legendäre Kolinas-Abendfolge in der Sauna Sindelfingen statt.
Vor der Sauna, ja?
Vor der Sauna, das stimmt. Aber das war mein persönliches Halterversicht, damit dabei sein konnte. Alex, wer ist denn in diesem Jahr mit dabei und was müssen wir über die Schiedsrichter wissen?
Es ist so, dass die Mehrzahl der Schiedsrichter nicht nur hier aus der Region kommt, damit sie nicht so einen weiten Weg haben, sondern eigentlich immer Schiedsrichter aufgeboten, wenn sie mindestens in der Oberliga pfeifen, meistens sogar in der Regionalliga. Das muss auch so sein, denn die Schiedsrichter, die hier pfeifen, müssen die Spieler natürlich oder müssen die Art von Spiel natürlich auch kennen. Das heißt, sie sind in der Regel auch durch die Aarjugend Bundesliga gegangen, vielfach zumindest pfeifen im höherklassigen Männerbereich. Es ist sogar eine FIFA-Schiedsrichterin hier. Das ist sicherlich auch die bekannteste Caroline Wacker FIFA-Schiedsrichterin seit 2017, Frauen-Bundesliga-Schiedsrichterin seit 2014 und Männer-Regional-Liga-Schiedsrichterin, damit in der vierten Liga unterwegs. Und das sieht man einfach auch. Für die Schiedsrichter ist es zum einen natürlich auch eine Anerkennung ihrer Leistung und eine schöne Belohnung, hier pfeifen zu dürfen, denn die pfeifen auch nicht jeden Tag vor 4500 Zuschauern. Heute wird es eben nochmal sicherlich was anderes werden, wenn es dann so richtig zur Sache geht. Das ist in den ganzen vergangenen Jahren aber immer zu beobachten gewesen. Sie sind eigentlich nicht wirklich das Thema. Sie haben schon einiges zu bewältigen. Das sind ja keine Freundschaftsturniere, muss man sagen. Es geht hier um was und das merkt man auch. Sie mussten in diesem Jahr zusätzlich noch gewisse Regeländerungen umsetzen. Das fand ich auch ganz interessant, denn in der Halle, wo es natürlich ein bisschen schneller zugeht, wirkt sich sowas auch nochmal deutlicher aus, als möglicherweise auf dem Feld. Also um da mal so ein paar Beispiele zu nennen. Man hat jetzt gestartet, dass der Torwart den Ball über die Mittellinie werfen darf. Das ist bis jetzt nicht der Fall gewesen. Da war immer Schluss, wenn der drüber geworfen hat. Da gab es einen Freistoß für den Gegner, einen direkten Freistoß. Jetzt dürfen die über die Mittellinie werfen, haben also nochmal eine ganz andere Möglichkeit, das Spiel zu beschleunigen. Oder eine Regelung, die aus dem Futsal mit rübergebracht worden ist. Es gibt einen Freistoß und wenn der nicht innerhalb von vier Sekunden ausgeführt ist, dann kriegt er einen Freistoß der Gegner. Das ist ja eine völlig ungewöhnliche Sache, die gibt es so auf dem Feld natürlich nicht. Und auch das beschleunigt das Spiel natürlich. Und wenn sich ein Spiel beschleunigt, hast du als Schiedsrichter oder Schiedsrichterin auch nochmal eine ganz andere Herausforderung natürlich, denn da musst du wesentlich schneller reagieren. Und es kam hier auch schon in einigen Spielen zum Schluss hin oder sogar nach dem Abpfifften zu. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, unschönen Szenen. Das wäre jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben, aber schon zu kleineren Scherbmützeln zwischen Spielern, da wo man schon merkt, das ist emotional, kocht es ja schon ganz schön hoch. Und ich bin gespannt, wie das heute wird. Aber sie haben das bis jetzt wirklich glänzend im Griff, muss man sagen. Und auch die Art und Weise, wie sie es auslegen, wie sie die Regeln auslegen. Es gibt ja auch ein Grätschverbot. Also wenn am Gegenspieler sozusagen gegrätscht wird, dann wird das immer abgefilft. Und daran halten sich normalerweise eigentlich auch alle. Das sorgt dann schon für einen relativ fairen Spielablauf. Aber das ist wie gesagt schon eine ziemliche Herausforderung hier bei dem Tempo.
Es ist sehr interessant zu sehen, auch wie der Stadionsprecher immer wieder auf das Publikum einwirkt. Dazu muss man sagen, es gibt hier einen Stadionsprecher, der die Spiele kommentiert. Da muss man sich am Anfang kurz dran gewöhnen. Aber dann hört man es vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr. Aber gerade bei strittigen Schiedsrichterentscheidungen erklärt der Stadionsprecher oft noch mal Regeln und sagt, ein völlig richtiger Pfiff, denn hier wurde zum Mann gegrätscht. Das ist auch am Finaltag noch sehr wichtig. Das kann ich euch schon mal prophezeien. Wenn dann irgendwann der VfB im Halbfinale spielt und dann hier die Halle kocht oder köchelt, dann wird auch der Stadionsprecher wieder eingreifen. Das finde ich einen interessanten Aspekt, weil das hat man logischerweise sonst im Fußball nicht.
Das kenne ich sonst vor allem nur ganz andersrum. Also solche Stadionsprecher, die dann wirklich sagen, in der 95. Spielminute geht der Gast aus XY durch einen klar unberechtigten Strafstoß und verdient mit 3 zu 2 in Führung. Alle schon selber auch gehabt, muss ich sagen, wo man dann da steht. Die Zuschauer nochmal so richtig angeheizt werden. Dass es mal andersrum läuft, dass jemand, wie du schon gesagt hast, nicht nur für den Schiedsrichter Partei ergreift, sondern sehr cool erklärt, völlig zurecht abgefiffen. Und aus diesen und jenen Gründen auch nochmal die Hallenregeln immer mal wieder anspricht. Denn das kennt halt auch einfach nicht jeder, der hier zuschaut. Das weiß nicht, was da passiert. Und fast letztes Jahr ist doch noch abgefiffen worden, wenn der Ball über die Mittellinie geht, sieht er das denn nicht. Und dann muss man halt was erklären. Und da sieht man aber natürlich auch, wie Stadionsprecher oder Hallensprecher, auch wenn der jetzt eben einen stärker kommentierenden Charakter hat und nicht keine reine Moderationsfunktion, wie sehr sie natürlich auch die Gemüter beruhigen können und wie wichtig ihre Rolle ist. Aber das nur so am Rande.
Ich würde da nur mal eine Frage in den Raum werfen. Und zwar ist es halt so, dass im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr mehrere Elemente aus dem Fußball tatsächlich in das Regelwerk übernommen wurden. Seht ihr das denn, dass man jetzt so langsam die Öffentlichkeit und auch die Spieler dafür bewusst macht, dass man irgendwie schon dann komplett zum Futsal übergeht? Oder soll es so dieses Hybrid aus Hallen, Fußball, Futsal und normalem Fußball bleiben?
Da bin ich selber gespannt. Ich sage mal kurz was zum regeltechnischen. Es ist eigentlich von Seiten des DFB ausdrücklich erwünscht und eigentlich sogar vorgesehen, dass Hallenturniere, die in Deutschland ausgetragen werden, nach Futsalregeln gespielt werden.
Ist aber nicht der Fall.
Es ist aber nicht der Fall. Du hast es Hybridlösung genannt. Das finde ich ein sehr schönes Wort dafür. Wo immer ich hinkomme, wenn ich sowas dann mal schaue, nicht nur hier in Sindelfingen habe ich das Gefühl, da gibt es sowieso eine Mischlösung. Das scheint also nicht durchgesetzt zu sein, weil es doch offensichtlich Teile, also in diesem Spektakel Teile des Regelwerks gibt, wo man sagt, das möchten wir gerne so beibehalten, möchten wir gerne am originären Fußball dranbehalten. Aber jetzt mit dieser Vier-Sekunden-Regelung, wenn es einen Freistoß gibt oder überhaupt eine Spielversetzung, und wenn nicht, dann wechselt die und der Gegner bekommt sie, das sorgt für mehr Tempo. Da habe ich auch schon Stimmen gehört, die gesagt haben, das müsste man auf dem großen Feld auch mal machen. Da geht die ganze Zeit schön in der Reihe auf. Keine Krebschuhe, keine Vier-Sekunden, aber vielleicht nach zehn Sekunden oder so was, und dann läuft das schon. Eigentlich ist es DFB-seitlich ausdrücklich erwünscht, dass das komplett umgestellt wird. Möglicherweise, wenn das jetzt bei dem Turnier der Fall ist, ist das ein Schritt, dass es grundsätzlich eher in diese Richtung geht.
Ich hoffe, du hast es eben angesprochen, das Element aus dem großen Fußball draußen zu übernehmen hat drin. Das ist natürlich der Fall, aber was bringt dann die Bande? Ich bin persönlich großer Verfechter von Futsal und ich würde mich freuen, wenn das dann auch bei solch prominenten und öffentlich wichtigen Turnieren der Fall ist, dass man dann wirklich die Leute für Futsal sensibilisiert und das dann eben auch den jungen Spielern gleich mit an die Hand gibt, sodass das dann in absehbarer Zeit vielleicht zum Standard wird. Denn Futsal hat sich ja in anderen Ländern nicht nur in Europa durchgesetzt und den Hallenfußball, wie es ihn in Deutschland gibt, den gibt es ja sonst eigentlich fast nirgendwo. Und ich störe mich halt immer sehr an diesen Szenen, wo dann einer an der Bande steht und irgendwie den Fuß auf dem Ball hat und einer kommt irgendwie dann von hinten, versucht zu stochern. Das hat für mich nichts mit Fußball zu tun, das ein Andauschport hat.
Ja, kann ich bestätigen. Ich habe immer noch hier einen blauen Fleck. Aber da hat die Kästin der Schiedsrichter vorher entschieden. Das wäre ein fairer Zweikampf gewesen. Da hätte ich mir einen Grafen aus Köln erwünscht. Also einen von jemandem anders aus Köln. Aber gut, das ist ein anderes Thema.
Wollt ihr doch mal über den Strafstoß reden? Magst du dir verursacht das?
Nee, wollen wir nicht drüber reden.
Deine Mannschaft von den einzigen wäre...
Den kann man schon geben. Meine Mannschaft hat mich aber so auf die Unterzeitsituation geschickt in der Defensive, dass ich da meine Mannschaft nicht beschweren kann.
Das kann ich bestätigen.
Dass es dann diesen Strafstoß gab. Ich glaube, dass die Regeländerungen weniger mit Wurzeln zu tun haben, als mit, wie das Turnier im letzten Jahr gelaufen ist. Das kannst du jetzt logisch weiß nicht wissen. Aber im letzten Jahr gab es viel mehr unentschiedene Spiele. Es sind weniger Tore gefallen. Und vor allem haben die Spieler dieses Torhüter darf nicht über die Mittellinie passen. Das haben die nicht gerafft gekriegt. Auch noch am zweiten Turniertag wurde das immer wieder abgepfiffen. Und vor allem diese Regeländerung ist es, glaube ich, die jetzt zu mehr Toren führt. Weil deswegen gibt es ganz viele weite Abwürfe. Es gibt immer einen Stürmer, der weit vorne postiert ist. Meistens in den Ecken. Und ich glaube, das hat weniger mit Futsal zu tun, als damit, dass man im letzten Jahr gesehen hat, dass im Vergleich zu den Vorjahren es ein bisschen weniger spannend war, ein bisschen weniger torreich. Natürlich wirst du hier die Tore sehen. Ich glaube, deswegen kommen die Regeländerungen zustande.
Aber beim Futsal haben sie sich ja auch trotzdem durchgesetzt. Es ist ja dann auch so, dass da trotzdem ein großer Spielfluss herrscht. Auch trotz der Tatsache, dass es keine Bande gibt, sondern der Ball, wenn er uns ausgeht, dann schnell reingespielt werden muss. Ich bin gespannt, wie dann im nächsten Jahr die Entwicklung der Regeln aussieht. Vielleicht ist ja dann die Bande weg.
Dann sind auch ganz viele Sponsoren-Banden weg.
Ich komme nur mit dem Fußball. Alles andere, das sollen andere Leute kennen.
Wir nehmen das mal mit und schauen mal, wie das im nächsten Jahr aussieht. Haben wir denn bei den Mannschaften Panotinaikos, Hoffenheim und Reykjavik noch jemanden übersehen? Ist euch da noch jemand ins Auge gesprungen?
Der Fallzweigzieher von Panotinaikos. Ich nenne den Fallzweigzieher.
In der Vergangenheit hatte man hier Markus Reschfeld mit United und so weiter. Es gab auch immer wieder internationale Stars oder Spieler, die den Durchbruch geschafft haben.
Ich denke, dass in diesem Jahr die ausländischen Mannschaften vom Reihenfußballerischen schon den Deutschen unterlegen sind. Ich bin nicht so stark dran.
Bis auf Panotinaikos und Reykjavik. Die einen versuchen es über Körperlichkeit zu lösen. Die anderen freuen sich vor allem, dass sie hier sein dürfen. Ich finde es krass, dass Zürich das ganz ansehnlich macht.
David Chassa hat gestern relativ viele Tore geschlossen, der mir ganz gut gefallen hat. Er war auch ein typischer Hallenspieler. Wie er sich jetzt draußen anstellt, kann ich natürlich nicht beurteilen, aber der ist mir positiv in Erinnerung geblieben.
Abschließendes Fazit, wie hat euch der erste Turniertag JuniorCup gefallen?
Ich finde es gut, Jugendmannschaften zu sehen, die man sonst nicht sieht, um zu schauen, wie das abläuft und auch mal mit anderen Leuten ins Gespräch zu kommen über die Ausbildung in anderen Vereinen. Das haben wir jetzt hier auch geschafft. Ich bin jetzt nicht hergefahren und habe gesagt, dass es nur ein gutes Turnier ist, wenn der RSF zu Köln gewinnt. Ich bin dann schon noch so weit, dass ich sage, die Ausbildung oder das Erlebnis ist für die Spieler wichtiger. Ich würde es der Mannschaft natürlich gönnen. Das ist auch in der A-Junior-Bundesliga gut unterwegs. Ich hoffe, dass sie heute noch mal ein bisschen was Positives mitnehmen können. Ansonsten finde ich das Turnier sehr, sehr gelungen. Über das Regelwerk lässt sich dann noch etwas diskutieren. Aber das wollen wir jetzt auch nicht nochmal ausbreiten. Insgesamt wirklich gute Sache.
Geht mir ähnlich. Ich finde es auch sehr erfreulich im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr und zum vorletzten Jahr, dass, wie du es schon ansprachst, es fallen mehr Tore. Es scheint ein bisschen mehr Feuer drin zu sein. Die Schiedsrichter haben mehr zu tun, weil der Ball teilweise auch schnell an einer ganz anderen Stelle ist, wenn er lang abgeworfen wird. Aber um das Wort Rudelbildung nochmal zu bringen, das haben wir gestern zwei, drei Mal gesehen, in zwei Jahren vorher glaube ich nie. Also es ist Feuer drin. In der Zwischenrundengruppe vom VfB ist es glaube ich super eng. Da können alle noch weiter kommen. Heute wird es nochmal richtig spannend. Und Glaspalast zum Jahresauftakt ist irgendwie schön, das ist immer so verlässlich. Die Speisenkarte ist die gleiche, die Leute sind die gleiche. Ich finde das irgendwie so eine Konstante in unserem bewegten Leben, der JuniorCup im Glaspalast.
Das finde ich auch. Und ich finde auch, dass dieser Wintertermin für ein Hallenturnier, ich meine, klar, im Sommer spielt man nicht in der Halle, aber bei mir weckt das immer noch Erinnerungen an früher, an Hallenmasters, wo man sich jeden Gig angeguckt hat. Ich saß den ganzen Tag vorm Fernseher, das war einfach herrlich. Und hier hat man es halt so ein bisschen komprimiert. Zwei Tage lang, viele Spiele, viele Tore. Den Reiz habe ich jetzt in denjenigen gesehen, der den Durchbruch schafft. Es gab auch durchaus schon Spieler, die hier gespielt haben, die dann danach eine bessere Karriere gemacht haben, wo ich mir dachte, was, der ist mir überhaupt nicht aufgefallen. Wo ich nicht sagen kann, lag das jetzt an mir oder am Spieler.
Ja, auch für mich, wie bei Arne, das erste Mal das Turnier, also von der Konstante kann ich noch nicht reden. Hoffentlich bald, wenn Hertha in den nächsten Jahren weiter teilnehmen sollte. Ansonsten gefällt mir das sehr, sehr gut. Also, wie du schon gesagt hast, die Stimmung wird ja heute eventuell noch mal besser, wenn dann mehr Leute kommen, weil es dann Wochenende ist und VfB und all die Faktoren reinspielen. Ansonsten, wie schon gesagt wurde, dass man sich auch mal Jugendspieler wirklich angucken kann, denn wenn man nicht Martin heißt, dann ist der Fokus manchmal nicht so da. Und dann weiß man, dass Spieler XY ein Talent sein sollen, kann es aber nicht selber beurteilen. Und hier hat man das auf sehr engen Rahmen mit vielen Spielen, vielen Aktionen und kann ihn bewerten. Das gefällt mir sehr gut. Nebenbei natürlich das Treffen hier vieler Leute, die man bei Cerno von Twitter kannte. Das ist auch gut. Und dementsprechend, das macht mir ja alles sehr großen Spaß. Und wenn Hertha heute das Ding noch holen sollte, dann macht mir das noch mehr Spaß.
Alex, du bist ja auch ein JuniorCup-Veteran.
Ja, das dritte Mal nacheinander. Man merkt sehr deutlich, wie sich die Regeländerungen ausgewirkt haben. Anna hat es ja schon gesagt. Das ist noch erheblich spektakulärer, als es in den vergangenen Jahren gewesen ist. Die Gruppen sind auch ausgeglichener, habe ich den Eindruck, als in den vergangenen Jahren. Ich hoffe, ich rede jetzt keinen Blödsinn. Das müsste man noch mal nebeneinander legen. Aber da sind für mich kuriose Ergebnisse dabei gewesen. Also wenn man das so versucht, gedanklich fortzusetzen, die einen schlagen die anderen 7 zu 2, wie gestern Hoffenheim, Panathinaikos, Athen. Und dann spielt der Panathinaikos gegen Bayern. Hab gedacht, naja gut, nachdem die Bayern vorher zwei Spiele gewonnen hat, das kann eigentlich nur ein klarer Sieg werden. Und dann ist das nicht der Fall gewesen. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Du willst uns aber nicht gerade sagen, dass dieses Turnier untippa wäre. Denn es spricht hier derjenige, der auf dem 2. Platz in unserem Tisch liegt. Oder du hast auch alles nur Glück.
Da findet aber auch das blinde Huen mal ein Korn. Ich bin ein grauenhaft schlechter Tipper normalerweise. Wenn ich oben stehe, spricht das eigentlich nur davon. Obwohl das jetzt ungerecht bei Martin vor mir noch liegt. Und er hat natürlich den absoluten Durchblick. Und ich habe den im Jugendfußball eher nicht. Deswegen habe ich da, glaube ich, eher viel Glück gehabt. Also ein spektakuläres Turnier, das mir sehr gut gefällt. Und bei dem die Schiedsrichter das sehr gut mithalten. Es gab so ein, zwei Situationen, wo ich mir ein bisschen mehr Präsenz gewünscht hätte. Auch bei den Anati-Rüddelbildungen, wo man so merkte, da ist so eine gewisse Überraschung da gewesen. Das kam auch aus dem Nichts. Aber das sind halt so Situationen, wo ein Schiedsrichter dann auch präsent sein muss, weil er dann auch dazwischen gehen muss und ihm klar sein muss, was habe ich jetzt zu tun. Und da gab es so ein, zwei Situationen, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, da könnte noch ein bisschen mehr kommen. Aber das soll die Leistung auf dem Feld, die es dann vorher gegeben hat, ehrlich gesagt, nicht schmälern. Und das haben wir alle gut gemacht.
Ich bin ja auch das erste Mal dabei, weil der FC Bayern das erste Mal seit über 20 Jahren dabei ist. Ich mag keinen Fußball generell, weil ich auch früher als Kind eigentlich lieber in der Halle gespielt habe, fast als draußen, weil da ging alles immer schön schnell. Und als jemand, der nicht so gerne gelaufen ist draußen, ist es auch in der Halle ein bisschen schöner, wenn man nicht so viel laufen muss. Aber das Tempo ist beeindruckend. Diese Regeländerung mit den vier Sekunden ist, glaube ich, sehr, sehr gut angekommen. Und das macht es ganz ehrlich, auch abwechslungsreich. Und es kann keiner so viel Zeit schinden. Es gab schon ein paar Situationen, aber das kann man auch recht schnell unterbitten.
Absolut. Ja, dann danke ich euch sehr, dass ich euch zu diesem spontanen Kurzpass hier eingewandt habe. Bei mir im Hotelzimmer. Ich danke Arne Steinberg, EdArnePuyol, bei Twitter, von fc.com. Danke, die Arne. Danke, Sebastian, Ed Butze, Ed Vertikalpass, von Vertikalpass.de. Danke, Mark Schwitzki, von HerthaBase.de, Ed Jungerhaar, 18, 92. Richtig. HerthaBase hat auch einen eigenen Podcast. Danke an Ed Liesers Welt, Alex Feuerherd, von Colinas Abend, Ed Colinas Abend, auch auf Twitter. Danke an Martin Brinkmann, Ed Napdo, FCB, von Mirsandroth unter anderem. Er ist ständig zu finden an allen Plätzen, an denen Junioren des FC Bayern spielen. Das war er, dieser Kurzpass zum Mercedes-Benz Junior Cup 2018. Ich hoffe, er hat euch gefallen. Lasst uns Feedback da. Würde mich interessieren, ob diese Folge für euch was gebracht hat, trotz meiner Erkältung. Und dass es halt doch nur ein Kurzpass ist. In diesem Sinne bleibt dem Rasenfunk gewogen. Liked uns bei Facebook, folgt uns auf Twitter. Könnt uns auch auf YouTube abonnieren. Und dann hören wir uns hoffentlich bald wieder, hier im Rasenfunk.